You saw nothing.
What's she doing down there?
What's what's she peeking over the counter for?
I'm shy.
Oh, I forgot music.
Hold on.
My music.
Music folder.
Wait, how loud is this?
How loud is this gonna be?
Hold on.
What's the music to put on?
What's my mood?
Sleepy.
I think this might put me to sleep.
Hold on.
I have to put on something that's not going to...
Maybe this.
Oh yeah.
Wait, why is it loud?
My, my, my, my, my, my my, my, my, my, my, my, my, my, my,
my, my, my, my, hello, everybody, welcome.
Hi!
Hello!
It's been a while.
Totally my fault.
Oh, nice catchphrase.
Thank you.
I've been saying it.
For many times.
Yeah!
Hi!
Hello!
was in japan i
have jet i almost said jet hag like for real i have jet lag
oh geez
i want to like play a game today because it's been like i
come back and i usually don't do like here's the things i
did on my trip because because usually i don't do anything
but I did a lot this time um but I also want to play a game
because that's been a long time since I since I've played
video game but we'll talk for now I'm so we missed you Vicky
Vicky I miss you I got to hang out with Vicky just a little
bit Hi!
Don't know for caffeine, thank you!
I'm drinking, I'm drinking, I'm drinking.
Mingo is stuck in my head.
Oh, because Alia called me Mingo.
Okay, we'll start.
We'll start from the very beginning of my trip.
Hold on, where's my phone?
I often base my trip off of like photos that I've taken,
right?
Phil, thank you!
Thank you so much!
Acoustic covers of popular MGS songs with the album title
called Big Boss Nova.
Wait, that sounds awesome!
Okay, hold on.
My photos.
I took a many.
There's only one thing I can't talk about yet.
will happen next year.
Oh, I zoomed too much.
So guys!
Oh gosh.
Mito is a visual creature.
I am!
I was gone on a family trip to London.
Cheerio.
Welcome back, boss.
Thank you so much, everybody.
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
I can't stop stretching.
Man.
I'm so...
Dired.
Yeah, I need a massage.
That.
I need this ectoplasm loosened up.
My hair is mint green now.
That's got matching.
Matches.
Let's see.
Okay.
I've learned something on this trip in particular I've
learned something I said That I would stream a couple times
on my trip And I truly had every intention to do so I don't
just bring my laptop And my whole streaming setup Because
that stuff is so heavy I I Yeah, I was a filthy liar.
I'm so sorry.
That's why I almost put that in the thumbnail.
Like, this streamer lied to you.
Sorry, I have still a bit of a cough.
How many times is it now that I've said that?
Well, okay, sometimes I do, though.
Another time.
I've learned, though.
I've learned from this trip in particular.
Oh, wait.
I just noticed something.
I forgot to put this on my mic.
Hold on.
It's gonna get kind of crunchy real quick.
There we go.
Sorry.
Yeah, I forgot to put the pop filter on.
That Twitter space still counts.
Does it?
What was I saying?
Oh, I learned on this trip that And I've felt it in other
trips before, but this trip solidified it.
So in the past, I would go on trips to Japan and I would
still stream because I didn't do anything.
And I really didn't hang out with people.
I didn't really hang out with people.
I would kind of just go out and do my own thing.
And this time, I hung out with friends, like almost every
day.
and it kept me busy you did the collab with Leah too yeah
yeah I have stories to tell about that as well so when I go
out with friends I'm usually waking up like I want to stream
early in the morning because I want to you know do around my
normal streaming time like now and this time if I'm staying
out with friends I'm waking up early and going out with
friends or I Or I am staying late and then I'm tired in the
morning.
I did get sick.
Yeah So I think I've learned that While this did turn into
work for me, it was like a it actually felt like a vacation
vacation It was kind of crazy.
There was I had plans like we all made plans and when I tell
you guys what it was going on you gonna be like how to why
you're gonna be like you guys are insane and I thought when
we were making these plans I was like something's gonna drop
like something we're gonna be like no we can't do that and
then we did everything and I was like why oh it was it was a
local streamer too popular too many friends I was my first
time really kind of going well I didn't go with everybody
but like this was like the largest group of people that I
had like hung out with maybe ever in Japan so I was like
whoa friends and there were people that wanted to see me and
I had to be like I'm sorry I can't I can't 32 people not
that many people close though close did any enemies into
friends no Why would I hang out with enemies?
But, no friends into enemies.
Which I think is even more impressive.
Because like when you travel with people, you know,
sometimes it's like, oh man, I hate that person now.
The way they brush their teeth annoys me.
The way they put on their socks annoys me.
The way they scratch their head annoys me.
You know?
Literally everything about them becomes a pain.
in your butt they're just living and you're like oh stop
living like that okay matara matara is like the only person
like that though she's a roach
but the first thing that we did that was crazy was everyone
was just like i i landed a little later than everyone that i
was hanging out with which i was hanging out with
And I was hanging out with Dustco.
I collabed with them.
And Oimo.
I hung out with Oimo.
We all collabed a couple days before I left.
And then...
And then we all went...
And we were hanging out in Japan together.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So that was a few people that I saw.
And...
living like that you say but with ghosts that does that
apply it does not it does not apply and so therefore you
cannot think that about me but let's see um uh so everybody
was like we're gonna go to Disney and that was like the day
after I got to Japan so I was like I'm probably not gonna do
that and i still did it
why why did i do that
it was peer pressure i sure they didn't even pressure me
they were like i think it was a fomo i think it It was FOMO!
Honestly!
I...
And I'll tell you, it was not worth it!
It was like...
It was...
It was... We rode three...
Okay, so I arrived Monday.
I arrived on a Monday that was a holiday in Japan.
And so I was like, well, that day would be so crowded at
Disney.
Tuesday will be fine!
Because everybody will have gone Monday.
And also, Tuesday is rainy.
It's cloudy.
It's ugly.
It's cold.
Nobody will go.
Oh, no.
I think everybody had the Mint Fanto mindset.
And rides were absolutely insanity.
Insanity.
There's one...
I'm a bit of a freak about...
about amusement parks.
It's my niche.
And I have the Disney Park app.
In fact, I will check it right now.
And I will just check it occasionally because I'm bored.
I'll check the...
Just to see how long lines are.
So I have a pretty good gauge.
I have a pretty good gauge of, like, the average times.
of lines at amusement park sometimes.
Not wait.
What time is it in Japan?
Oh, okay, okay.
The park just opened.
Okay, it's 9.20 in Japan.
And because I saw one of the rides only had a 50-minute
wait.
It opened 20 minutes ago, by the way, and already has a
50-minute wait.
But that's very low for that ride, so I was like, whoa,
whoa, what's going on?
on they're flopping the park is closing yeah only 50 minute
wait yeah yeah yeah
but um but yeah so that's low that ride usually has like a
hundred and eighty minute wait one one 150 to 180 about yeah
50 minute wait the place really fell off they're they're in
shambles nobody's going
holy hell you're telling me you're telling me um we got to
ride three rides My first time at Tokyo Disney was rainy,
but it still had fun.
My friend slipped and fell on Tom Sawyer's hat.
Oh, no!
Well, I usually, I don't usually check Disneyland, or Tokyo
Disneyland.
I usually check Tokyo Disney Sea.
That's like one of my favorite parks ever.
Uh, we got to, there's one ride called 20,000 Leagues Under
the Sea.
a 20 minute wait the weight when we went was 50 minutes it's
it's situations like that there's one ride called Sinbad
that I have lovingly dubbed as all reliable because the ride
is amazing it's like a 15 minute ride it's it's it's bet
it's oh my god it's so good a one minute per one thousand
leaves
the best ride at Tokyo Disney Sea it's like 15 minutes long
it's a it's like it's a small world but the animatronics are
really impressive and the song is much better than it's a
small world it's the perfect dark water ride and the weight
is always always at five minutes it's all reliable if you
can't ride literally anything at Tokyo Disney Sea Sinbad has
your back and I was convincing everybody I was like you guys
we have to go on Sinbad it's all reliable if you're tired
get on Sinbad you can ride nearly immediately you can just
go on the ride sit for for 15 minutes you have you have a
great experience I think I'm exaggerating about the time.
But still, it's really long.
You think the ride is over and then it keeps going.
It's great.
It's so awesome.
Sinbad, five minutes.
You know how I know that the times were bad?
15 minute wait.
15 minute wait for my old reliable.
It's... That's how you know.
That's how you know things are in dire states.
It's over.
It's three times.
I know!
I have never once seen the queue of this ride.
Never once have I seen the queue of this ride except when I
went.
Except that day.
I was like, I was like, whoa.
There's decorations!
Yeah, and then we went on...
We went on my favorite ride at the park, which was Journey
to the Center of the Earth.
It's so great.
Oh, sorry.
I'm kidding.
I saw someone ask if I am a screamer or stoic on roller
coasters.
I'm more like this.
The whole time, I'm just like...
But nothing is coming out of my mouth.
I'll just be like...
Because I'm having fun.
I'm not like...
And sometimes I'll go...
Woo!
But I wouldn't say I'm stoic in like a...
Like I'm still enjoying myself.
journey to the center of the earth was my favorite ride
there too it's um oh my gosh it's a Tokyo Disney Sea
exclusive ride so I recommend it if even if you don't like
roller coasters there's one drop it's a little steep I'll
give it that but it is it is just a really awesome ride I I
rant and It's so good.
It's so...
It's... Oh, I really can't just...
Is that the three-hour one?
Yeah.
It is the three-hour one.
But it's such a great ride.
Apparently with family to visit Disney World and Universal.
Epic Universe!
I want to go to Epic Universe!
Sally will leave Florida before holiday.
Matsuri takes place.
No!
Glad to have a great...
I'm glad to have a great vacation boss.
We'll come back.
Thank you.
um but yeah uh did that we rode also we rode journey to
center of the earth we are we rode sinbad and then we rode
the rapunzel the tangle ride which that ride makes me cry
because it's so beautiful but it also is like the shittiest
ride it makes me so angry it seriously makes me mad it is a
new ride it's part of the new fantasy springs park that
opened up at at Disney see also thank you guys so much for
all that super chance thank you thank you thank you thank
you aerodynamics documentary by ace for a fellow amusement
park nerd oh look into it thank you give me the courage to
visit my first ever me cafe cafe de eye oh my gosh in Kyoto
sounds awesome okay I'll tell you why I hate it okay I
already see people saying why I hate it it is literally like
people are saying in the chat it's five seconds long and
when we were waiting in the line I think it was a hundred
and twenty minute wait no it was a hundred minute wait and
we ended up waiting two and a half hours yeah and it is
extremely short so basically the animatronics in it amazing
so expressive so beautiful you go in it's a boat ride it's a
dark ride well I don't even know do you count it as a dark
ride part of it's outside half of it's outside it's that
short okay sorry you get traveling outside on a little river
you you look up and you can see Rapunzel singing in the
tower it's really cute you can actually see her from outside
the right as well and then on the on your left you see Flynn
Rider Eugene you see him and he's like and then you go
inside oh you see also um the horse stream labs disabled no
i think they're just very backed up but i see yours yen way
thank you i wait i have watched that thing about terminus i
know exactly what that is yeah you see maximus the horse and
then you go inside And you see, you see Rapunzel swinging
along the tree on one part.
She's like flying through the tree with her hair.
And Eugene is like, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
This stupid girl.
Then you see the snuggly duckling.
You only see it.
You don't go inside.
Then the next room, you, uh, is Rapunzel healing Flynn's
hand, Flynn Rider's hand with her hair?
And then the next room is them singing At last I see the
light In a boat, which is so beautiful And you circle around
them and then the ride's over
Is it TLDR of the movie?
No, not even
I've waited two and a half hours for that
In the freezing cold It rained a little bit.
It was so...
I mean, again, it's so beautiful.
That part alone is so nice.
But what I also think they really do you dirty.
They do you dirty is your circling...
Here, let me see if I can find a picture.
At least.
Tangled Ride.
Tokyo Disney Sea.
It's so messed up.
Okay.
Seeing this pisses me off.
This ride makes me so angry.
I wonder if I look up like a...
I went on the Tangled Ride.
This is how long it took.
Tangled Ride, Tokyo Disney.
Let's see how long the video is.
Five minutes?
No, it's not even.
Maybe five minute long.
Maybe.
I don't know.
It's...
And what sucks is I love Tangled.
Okay, this is what the room looks like.
It's gorgeous, no?
It's so beautiful.
They're singing the song and the animatronics look amazing.
It literally looks like the scene from the movie taken out
and put into this room.
It's really awesome.
But you see, hold on, let me get a pointer.
Let me get a pointer.
Uh...
Do I have a little mouse somewhere?
Hold on.
Uh...
Let me use...
No, he's not a PNG.
Um...
It's awesome.
I know!
It's...
So pretty!
Why don't I have a pointer?
Okay, I'm gonna use this guy.
Actually, no, I'm gonna use... Okay.
The little...
The little, this, the wispy part.
Like, look at the top of the head, okay?
You see the carts down here?
They go around like this.
So you get a full angle, like a full view of them singing.
And it's very cute and romantic and beautiful.
But imagine me.
I'm sitting right here, okay?
I'm sitting right here.
There's a car right over here, right?
There's me.
Sobbing.
Crying.
tears streaming down my face I'm like and then there's
people over there looking at me they can see everything
and then also I'm here trying to get every beautiful angle
of Rapunzel's cute little face and who do I have in the
background some OG sign some some little child in the
background who's pogging being like the entire time get out
of my shot
that's my besides the length of the ride that is my biggest
complaint because here I I am desperately, desperately
trying to wipe tears from my face so that nobody can see me.
Do you watch the Funkland?
Of course I watched the Funkland.
But I haven't watched the new video.
I haven't had time.
Do not perceive Minto.
It's so embarrassing.
Is there news with our fan name?
No.
Don't ask.
Ask!
We're working on it!
It's a work in progress!
But yeah, so that was literally my first day at Disney.
Sorry to rant about.
Sorry to rant about so much of it.
Oh.
Let's see.
Um, after that, uh, the day after, I went to some tea.
I went to Tay with my friends.
Oh, I also went shopping with Dust Go.
I helped her pick out some stuff.
So, um, it was crazy.
New Epcot Fireworks Show Mashes Up Remember Me and She Loved
Me.
No.
That's messed up.
Oh my gosh, Dan, thank you so much for that.
For after, thank you.
I don't want to talk about fan names right now.
Thank you, though.
Do I like GU clothing?
Yeah!
I like GU, which is kind of strange that they're only in
Japan because they're Uniqlo.
I feel like they could expand internationally just like
Uniqlo did, no?
So...
Hmm...
I don't know, I don't know.
There's one in New York now.
Ah, see?
There are GU in the US.
They're in Taiwan too.
Oh, see?
So, yeah.
And then, let's see.
Then, the day after, I went to an idol event.
And I got to see an idol, and she was like, she was like,
Chad?
Why are you here?
My... You guys, my gotcha luck has been insane!
Insane!
This...
This... this... this trip...
Recognized.
I know!
She's so sweet.
I actually got to meet her at the Toho Lost Word...
Uh, Toho Lost Word event.
And so I was like really happy she remembered me.
And then she was like I've been wanting to message you but
I'm so shy and I was like me too I've been wanting to
message you but I'm so shy so and then she was like let's go
hang out and play in Akihabara what's so sad is she's
retiring next year she's been having some she was a member
of Dempagumi Inc her name is Nemoto Nagi a part of Nijino
Conquistador and then she joined so Denpa Gumi Inc.
And she left the groups, well yeah she left the groups and
then she's been doing kind of like solo activities and stuff
and then and next year she's retiring like from
entertainment so I'm like So I was like, I have to go see
her as many times as possible now.
So I really wanted to make it out to this event.
And this event was gotcha.
It was lottery.
And it's a very small venue.
So I was really happy that I could go see her.
I was so happy.
That was one thing of my good gotcha.
But the other thing was, I went with Vicky.
Vicky and I were there together.
like Nemo had these like decorated checky cases that she
made herself and she was like if you want one you have to
rock paper scissors for it um it's kind of funny you had to
rock paper scissors for it to then pay for it is Vicky's
gotcha luck contagious or did you absorb all her luck I
don't know maybe maybe I absorbed her luck or something
because what it happened was there were hold on I took a
picture there were six of them there were six of them and
everybody did rock paper scissors and Vicki won one she won
one and unfortunately I lost the very I was like the last
person cut I was like dang it no I wanted one but that's
okay and then they were like wait a second we miscounted we
only chose five people and so Nemo she was just like you get
one you get one so it was crazy so i got to luckily give one
as well i was so happy no wonder i felt a chill while i was
in japan the last two weeks yeah
yeah so both vicky and i both able to get one.
It was really nice.
Nemo was so, so cute.
The cutest.
But the day after that
we were like, okay.
Alright, gang.
We're going to Fuji Q Highland.
I was like, oh my gosh, I've been waking up early every
morning up to
this and if you don't know Fujiki Highland it's obviously by
Mount Fuji this was the one of the things that I was like
okay this is probably gonna get cut we're not gonna go nope
no we we had to be on the bus at 6 a.m.
6 a.m.
On the bus!
We have to be!
In!
Shinjoku!
Bye then!
Oh wait, no, sorry, 7 a.m.
Sorry, wait.
Wait.
I might remember, wait.
I don't remember.
Wait, 6 or 7?
Wait, maybe the original was 6 and then...
I don't remember.
It was early.
I'm gonna kill you all.
I will kill you myself.
I will- shut up.
Shut up!
I am-
It's not funny!
Stop trying to make fetch a thing!
That's what you guys sound like.
Please!
You are so millennial.
Nah, you guys are so stupid!
I don't make millennial jokes, at least.
Well, yeah, I do.
Do I?
I don't know.
Also, it's all the millennials that are making the jokes,
too.
Everybody's adopting 6-7.
Don't say I'm a millennial, just because...
Yeah, you could say I'm Boomer.
I'm drinking tea right now, so I have some caffeine in me.
Okay, boomer.
Yeah, I'm a boomer.
Use code boomer for...
What is it?
How much...
A number off your gamer subs?
Use code boomer for...
10% off gamer subs.
Thank you.
some amount did you guys see that picture that was like an
ad for a sponge bop game that was like mr.
crabs holding up the sign and it says the game is 67% off
but the catch was the the picture was ai generated right and
what's funny is people were like you don't even need to show
me the the weird artifacting in the image for me to know
that this is ai generated because there's no way that mr
crabs would be excited about a discount that that is of his
own product
mr crabs could never be happy
I went to Fujiqu!
It was so cold.
Holy moly!
Was it cold?
But it was so beautiful.
I think the best days to go to Fujiqu are the cold days.
Because typically like the sun, it's like, you know how like
a cold, crisp day is is like where the sun is out and
there's no clouds in the sky.
And it was just so, woo!
Did you take any pics?
I took a ton of pics, but I'm kind of lazy to get them off
my phone.
I haven't gone through them to make sure they're safe too,
some of these.
But I love Fujikyu.
It's probably my favorite theme park because the rides are
insane.
The rides are insane.
The roller coasters are actually crazy.
thrill rides it's so the not safe for work theme park face
oh yeah I do have a close up picture of Tsunade's boobies
because there's a little Naruto park
yeah oh my gosh you guys oh my gosh you guys eh janaika is
crazy eh janaika eh janaika eh janaika here I'll show you
guys that picture Hold on.
That's just one picture I can upload.
Unfortunately, though, we didn't get to ride Takashiba
because by the end of the day, it was so cold and we were so
tired.
But, what is it?
Oh my gosh.
Fujiyama is like one of my favorite roller coasters of all
time.
It's so long and the drops are so crazy.
And it's so much fun.
I love it.
I love, love, love it.
Wait, hold on.
Where's her boobs?
Boobies!
Where are you?
Um...
Because...
Yeah, we went on...
There's a new ride, too, called Zokon, that I got to ride.
It was pretty funny because we were like seeing it from the
outside and we were like...
We were like...
This ride looks not so intense.
Like it looks pretty slow.
It's like a... It's like a bike style.
So...
So... Shut up.
Why are you guys like this today?
Shut up!
We're making it for the most time.
Oh my gosh, I just realized there's like a crack on the
statue.
Welcome back, Min.
Thank you.
Home.
Um.
Here's the picture.
Whoa!
It's big.
Hold on.
Fit to screen.
There we go.
You're welcome.
I think they nerfed her, honestly.
I think they're bigger.
In the show no you sound like boobies is a pet name of a pet
you but yeah zokan end of end of ride name nothing else
following she's low on chagra uh zokan we were looking at it
we're like this doesn't seem very fast and but there were
signs leading up to it that were like they were like this
ride is more intense then then you think this ride is more
extreme then then you realize and like everything was very
much like do not do not take your hands off the handlebar do
not like place like make sure your back is like this like
all this stuff and I was like what the heck this is kind of
crazy but but the show they were almost as big as her head
oh crazy
but then when you get on the ride it actually was really I
thought I was gonna slip out of my seat I'm not gonna I'm
not gonna lie did you ride Ejanaika yeah of course I rode
Ejanaika there is not a roller coaster that I will not ride
I'm a bit of a thrill-seeker you guys I'm a bit of a
thrill-seeker so um the ride was kind of insane actually it
was super and then they were also because it was like a bike
style they were like when you were turning lean into the
turns things like that so it was pretty cool I was it was
pretty neat Ejj and Nyka is really fun.
The only thing that I have an issue with it is one thing
that I love about roller coasters is that pit feeling in
your stomach when you drop.
And the way that Ej and Nyka works is essentially they send
you up the ride backwards.
Thank you so much.
We're like, I have to attack you.
the ride backwards but then the ride how do i even explain
this it flips you around while you are like on the ride like
it's turning there they advertise like 14 rotations or
something yeah i love airtime give me all the airtime
everything i love it i love it
So, you don't really like feel...
You just are so disoriented the whole time.
It's kind of fun, though.
I went on the Kidney Stone roller coaster.
One's 10 out of 10.
Uh...
Big Thunder Mountain?
Mm-mm-mm-mm-mm-mm.
So, it's...
It's...
It's less barf-inducing than it seems.
I don't know.
It's kind of crazy.
Hey, Sparta!
Happy birthday!
But yeah...
It's crazy!
It's a lot of fun though.
We went in the haunted house.
That was fun.
We got yelled at though, by the...
Okay, there were like...
Character actors, right?
Like in the haunted house.
We were walking by!
And like, they were like, it was like a small little...
A small little hallway.
And we were like pressed against the wall.
And we were like talking to them.
We were like, Año!
Año, tell me my name!
You know, like being stupid people.
Because like, we weren't heckling them or anything.
We weren't like, ooh, you suck!
We weren't doing anything bad.
We were just kind of like, Año!
Don't hurt us, don't scare us, please!
We're just stupid foreigners!
Hehehehehe!
And then they like looked up at us.
and broke character and they were like don't act like that
towards the actors please follow the rules and then walked
away and we were like oh was that part of the we were like
we were like was that part of that it was kind of scary that
was the scariest part that was the scariest part of the
haunted house It was kind of, like they were like, Chanto,
Ruru, A Momote Kutasai.
And then like walked away.
It was so scary!
That would have ruined my day.
Honestly, like, it was towards the beginning of the haunted
house.
And if you know the haunted house at Fujikyu, it's about
like 30 to 40 minutes long.
It's quite long.
And...
Oh my gosh, that's how well thank you so much.
Thank you!
The fact that they were like, I was like, Oh my gosh.
Like, please follow the rules.
Remember the rules.
That was so scary.
It felt, it did kind of like put a damper on our mood, but
we were fine afterwards.
It was just kind of like, dang, okay.
I was like, what are we supposed to do?
Why do we?
Why are they so mad?
Like, I thought everybody would kind of be like, well, we
didn't touch them at all, of course.
I guess they were upset that we were, like, talking to them.
I have no idea what the rule was.
Fun is banned.
Japan is kind of, like, weird like that sometimes about
certain things.
I don't know.
It was so strange.
It was really, yeah.
But, you know, we just kind of kept going.
and didn't let it let it get to us too much but it was it
was i'm never i never have it's had something like that
happened to me before so i was like what the huh i don't
know
do not have fun outside of funds approved fun zones yeah so
i guess be careful if you go to the to the haunted house in
Fujikyu because they'll be like don't talk to them I guess I
don't know I'm like really bad I'm like such a I'm such a
little wimpy baby where it's just like if I break the rules
I'm like I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry and then right now
like there's like pretty bad foreigner sentiment in Japan so
I always try to be like very I'm like I'm like respectful
you know because I'm like I don't want that I don't want
them to think like that like all foreigners are bad you know
things like that so I'm very like you know so I was just
like what the heck oh my gosh I didn't expect it but it
didn't it didn't ruin our time at all it was just very
shocking and uh uh then we went on this one oh my gosh me
and Vogel we were on this swing ride that like takes you
super duper um high in the air if you sing 24 hours
cinderella in your next karaoke i'll be my wish you forever
i've been meaning to learn it i gotta learn it but the swing
ride takes you super duper it's one of those like rides that
like spins you around kind of right um and it takes you
really really high up and it was like the best view of
Fujisan, it was so beautiful, but it was freezing.
It was so cold.
And there was like a part where like you would be against
the wind, like you would be rather like the wind wouldn't
hit you until you only reached a certain area of the swing.
And so Mogu and I would be like,
every time.
It was so bad.
I would just be like, Vogue!
Vogue!
What are we doing up here?
It was so...
They've become very extremely strict, I've noticed, on
rides.
Especially Fujikil.
Essentially, somebody...
I think somebody died.
They, like, broke their back on a ride.
That ride is now decommissioned.
But I think ever since then they've been super like...
No, nothing, no this, no that.
So like...
I really wanted to bring my phone.
You know how parks, like amusement parks in the States?
They don't care at all.
They're like, you drop your phone, goodbye forever.
But here they're just like, um, you know, you could drop
your phone and your belongings, but, um, and we can't get
them back for you if that...
happens, but also, we're going to scan you.
We're going to make sure, we're going to check your pockets
to make sure you have nothing in there.
You can bring literally nothing onto this ride.
My friend had, had trash, literal like a receipt trash in,
in, in, in the pocket.
And, and the, attendant was like no you have to you have to
take that out and go put it in the locker and then and make
them and it was crazy I was like trash a receipt a literal
receipt paper paper and they made her go back through and
like took us a wand and wand and wand their pants again i
was like this is insane this is so
like you i wanted to bring my phone for the for the swing
but because i wanted to take nice video of mount fuji no not
even possible the paper is a choking hazard yeah i
understand phones especially because if like that happens to
land on the track that's a huge issue Or, you know, if it
drops, like, that's obviously...
That sucks, but my god!
Not having anything in your pockets at all!
Is insane!
Falls on someone's head.
Yeah, yeah, of course, yeah.
If it falls on someone's head, yeah.
Anything falling out of your pockets that would fall on your
head is, of course, extremely dangerous as well.
What food did I eat over there?
Oh my gosh, so much!
I ate a ton.
I ate so much sushi though.
I'm addicted to sushi though.
What made you throw up?
I'm getting there.
Don't worry.
Hamazushi better?
No.
No, no, no!
Also, there's less hamazushi than there is sushi though,
first of all.
I will say though better than, better than kurazushi.
Kurazushi.
But...
Um...
Sushiro has the salmon basil...
Salmon basil pesto roll.
And it's like the best thing ever.
I say roll, it's a nigiri, but it's so...
Good!
Did you get all the Miko-chi collab stuff?
I saw it, but I did not get anything.
So yummy.
So yummy!
Welcome back, Minto!
Thank you!
Yeah, that basil sushi?
You guys, it's so good!
It's so good!
Gosh, it's so delicious.
For business purposes, you appreciate all sushi chains.
Yes, I appreciate all sushi chains for business purposes.
Let's see, though.
So Fujikil was a lot of fun, but of course it was extremely
busy.
It was an extremely long day because they get there very
early.
But what's crazy is I didn't realize this.
The park closes at 6 p.m.
6 p.m.
So, I've never heard of a park closing so early.
I was like, wait, really?
Am I getting this wrong?
Yeah.
Super duper early.
Oh my gosh, thank you for the sushi fun.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Was that when it started getting dark?
It is.
But I like, you know, I guess I really love Fujikyu for the
view of Mount Fuji.
But I also love it for the ride.
So I was just so...
That's why, yeah, you need to get there early.
Otherwise, you'll miss the entire park.
So that was fun.
Oh my gosh, one thing you guys asked about Mikuchi Sushiro.
But one thing that was also happening was Roboko-san.
Roboko-san was doing a collab at Kier-Made Cafe.
So I did get to go to that.
Yeah, actually I think that was the only maid cafe I got to
be able to make it out to.
But she had like... hold on, I have a picture.
It's really cute.
Hold on.
Let me...
Oh, wait.
Oh gosh.
Uploading pictures to Discord mobile sucks.
Hold on.
I have to like scroll through.
Wait, where is it?
Huh?
Oh, hold on.
Wait, oh, I can do multiple.
Okay, okay.
Good, good, good.
Wait, let me double check that this one's okay.
The food was yummy, though.
It was very cute and so yummy.
Double checking, double checking.
Looks.
I have to crop this man out.
Sorry.
I didn't realize he was in my picture.
I didn't crop any of these.
Sorry.
Let me crop this man out.
The art form was so good.
It was so, so cute.
OG San begun, yeah.
OG San eraser.
Erase.
A little bit more.
Erase!
Okay.
You can see his fingers.
I'm so sorry.
Um, so this was...
The food I got.
That's a stew.
That's a... Hold on.
It's like a... It was like a...
Chicken stew.
Um, I love the gears.
I thought they were super, super cute.
You see how many little gear pastas there are?
Exactly three.
Yeah, that's all I got.
That's all that was in there.
Yeah.
Exactly.
They were like, yeah.
And then the parfait was like a sesame pudding and then a
peach drink, which was very good.
Peach, wait, was it peach?
I can't remember.
But look at this.
Look at this.
Da!
Look!
It's me!
In the Curavade Cafe.
Enjoying.
The collab.
Yeah.
What kind of ice cream?
I think it was a strawberry ice cream on top.
And I remember the tea was not...
It was not sweetened at all.
See?
So, the ice cream really sweetened it well.
It was nice.
That's me in the maid cafe.
Yeah.
Awesome, I know.
And then there was a...
In the same building, in the Onoden building, there's like a
downstairs area.
And they had... Look at this screen!
Oh, you see that guy's fingers.
Oh, no.
Don't sue me.
Look at this screen!
And they had like all the artwork and stuff.
cool yeah it was nice it was really really nice finger dogs
of that guy some some what are loboko's fans called I really
like the curved the curved screen it's so cool
no bossa yeah some some who's gonna sue me so sorry so sorry
let's see but yeah i did get to go to that um
uh then i did some wait oh i i did not talk about i didn't
take any pictures um from leah uh uh i was if you didn't see
i was in um face connect leah's 3d debut Okay, I have
something really funny to say about this.
She invited me.
She invited me quite a bit ago.
Luckily, my date just happened to overlap.
It was like pure coincidence.
I was like, oh my gosh, thank goodness I don't have to go
back to Japan for, you know, like it was really lucky
timing.
I got me minto blush this weekend.
Thank you.
Did you go to Chikawa Park?
No!
I'm not super into Chikawa, so I didn't go.
Um, I just like it, but I'm not like a super duper fan.
Um, Leah did such a good job in her 3D.
She did!
Yeah!
Um, but...
Do I have a favorite Chikawa?
I like Momonga!
But anyway, Leah invited me and I was like, sure, of course.
And then I saw that they announced their 3D debuts and I was
like, oh, cool.
I guess, I guess like she'll announce because usually, okay,
I've always, or not always, but like, usually things that I
participate in are like filmed and recorded in advance,
right?
So I was like, okay, um, I guess maybe she'll have her 3D
debut, and I thought for some reason that the thing, that I
was going to be a part of, was her birthday.
And so I was like, oh, she might announce her birthday thing
that I'll be a part of during the 3D debut.
I get there.
We're practicing and setting up.
And then she was just like, okay, so for tomorrow.
And I was like, huh?
Tomorrow?
Wait, what?
And then she was like, yeah, it's live.
And I was like...
And guys, oh my god, I was so...
This is when I was really sick.
Luckily I wasn't like...
I didn't have like super sickness, but for like a cold I was
pretty sick.
Check the JLPT.
Oh my gosh, good luck!
Good luck, good luck.
When I was doing that dance, my vision was like...
I don't know how I got through it.
I...
I had taken some medicine right before.
And, like, my vision was, like, going in and out.
It was so bad.
I'm glad that we talked before and then did the dance.
Because I was, like...
I was like, oh, my God.
This is so bad.
And I...
I messed up!
But luckily, the camera would cut.
And I was like, I got so lucky.
I thought I was literally gonna pass out.
Wouldn't that have been so bad if I passed out?
If I passed out...
Like live?
In somebody else's 3D day...
view that would have been so bad well imagine all like the
clips of me falling and just being like wasted it
would have been so embarrassing so but I it was funny um
when i was like practicing with her um
sakana this didn't tell me the right time i was i was there
at noon and i was like okay i'm here i'm ready and then he
was like huh he was like um i'm far away i was like what do
you mean by that he was like oh nobody told you the updated
time yeah nobody told me the updated time i even got there
early i was there like i was there like 15 minutes early
because i was like i'm gonna be responsible she's probably
already like practicing so hard and everything so
It was good though.
It's fine.
We made him go to the convenience and buy us snacks.
And I made him get me an Uber home.
Yeah.
I was like, um.
Give me.
Nah, he offered, actually.
I was like, I'm looking for a taxi now.
And he was like, oh, do you want me to call you one?
Yeah.
So that was good.
And, um...
Yeah.
So...
Let's see.
Didn't you get banned from Uber?
Yeah, I'm banned from Uber.
I can't...
I can't use Uber in Japan.
It's because I can't...
I can't...
I can't call.
I can't have an account for some reason.
And it sucks because there's also like a Go Taxi app.
And for some reason it won't accept my card.
So I can't like call a taxi there.
I always have to like manually go into the street and find a
taxi.
So I can't.
I have no idea what I do.
I did.
I've already talked about this, but no.
For those that don't know, I've been banned from Uber.
I don't know why.
I only used it a couple times before they banned me.
I think, though, it was because I, back in the day, I had
heard that Uber drivers do not, or like, I guess, not just
Uber drivers, but, um, like, the shared, shared rider,
shared drivers, they don't like you to drive drivers.
amount of distances and it happened right after anime expo
and my hotel was not far away but it was just close enough
that it was like a five-minute drive so I would keep
requesting ubers back and forth because I was not going to
walk by myself in the downtowns of LA so I think maybe maybe
they got mad at me and Maybe they gave me a bunch of
one-star reviews because I kept asking for short trips.
I heard that they don't like short trips for some reason.
I don't get it.
What else was I supposed to do, though?
I can't walk.
Mint has never been to Uvu Java.
They don't like money?
I guess not.
And I tip.
I tip by drivers.
And sometimes people will be like, wow, you're tipping.
Like, people don't tip anymore.
I'm like, what?
I tip.
Uber driver here.
It was me.
I did it.
For funsies.
Ew.
They felt like you wasted their time.
And maybe it is.
Maybe.
Did you get ectoplasm on their seat?
No!
I do my best.
I try not to.
Maybe a little bit.
I once had a Japanese cabbie.
Take my luggage out of the car and told me to walk because
the distance was too short.
Still charged me one kid.
No way!
What?
Taxis don't even start until 500 yen.
That's crazy.
Actually, the first time I was taxiing to the airport this
time, go home and This is the first time it's ever happened
my Taxi driver.
He was just like he was like This is so weird.
He couldn't find the entrance for where the taxis go He was
like backing up in the middle of the street And he was like
driving around and he's like I think I got a U-turn over
there He's like sorry.
I've only been to this airport like three times and
And he, he, he was just like, I'm so sorry that I got lost.
Um, here's, he was like, he was like, the amount added up to
this amount, but I'm going to give you back a thousand yen
as like a bill.
I've never had a taxi driver like, he like, he was like,
here.
Here's 1000 yen!
I was like, Oh, I don't...
Okay!
Yeah, he was really nice.
The live rebate.
That was nice of him.
I've never had...
Well, I was gonna...
I don't think...
He was really old, which is also very funny.
I don't think I've ever had a bad experience with a taxi
driver in Japan.
Because most of the time, like 90% of the time, they're like
very quiet.
They just don't bother you.
I have had people though that have like, that have driven
very poorly.
They'd be like, you know, like things like that.
But no one that was ever actively mean or anything.
But, okay, I have a confession.
I don't know if I've ever said this before.
for I've never been to Osaka I just never I've never been to
Osaka I've never been to Kyoto I've just never had a reason
to go out of all of my trips most of the time they also end
up being like work trips so I've never been to I've always
just had to stay in Tokyo and this past trip this past trip
I went to Osaka I went to Osaka for the first time I stayed
in a little real time with my friends it was very nice it
was but here's my experience with Osaka taxi driver we
needed to get a taxi to to the to the real con the Nancy
your experience oh yeah baby oh yeah baby um was there a
robot cat unfortunately no oh i think it was haunted it
might have been haunted rio con uh but
um what was it saying oh yeah the website for the rio con
said that the shuttle to the Ryokan stops at 2 p.m.
We got there at 3.
So we were like, okay, well, I guess we gotta get a taxi.
Little, little did we know.
The taxi driver was just like, hey, that shuttle?
He literally points to it, driving by.
And he says, right there.
Thank you for your business.
Next time you're in LA, can you try getting away mode?
No, I don't want to drive away mode.
But also, the taxi driver, he was just like, why are you
guys here?
We were like, oh yeah, we're staying at this Ryokan.
He's like, are you going to this temple?
That was in the nearby area.
We were like, ah, no, probably not.
We don't really have time.
He was like, what?
Why are you
It's such a waste that you're not going.
We were like, okay, we have a little bit of time.
We could probably, once we get to the Ryokan, we will hike
there.
Our taxi driver, while yelling at us that this is a waste of
our time to not go to this temple, gets...
He almost gets into an accident with a bus and the bus honks
at him, okay?
And, um, so then at the next light, the driver proceeds to
get out of the bus, I mean, get out of the taxi, and starts
to walk over to the bus to throw hands.
And we were like, only in Osaka maybe.
This is my first Osaka experience.
happened before ever we were just like oh my god oh my god
oh my god beginning of the next chelazard game hi
i miss you i hope you feel better did he win i guess so he
came back and continued to drive us
it was so crazy but the real kind was very nice um There was
like a path.
We were like, okay, there's a path to like this temple that
he talked about.
Like a little...
I say a path.
It was really a hiking trail.
I am...
In my dress.
I am not prepared for the outdoors.
Playing yakuza has made me realize you don't mess with taxi
drivers.
Clearly.
Why?
We're walking along this path.
We're hiking.
We are like, the path has like, it's on a steep cliff even
and has like this tiny little rope that you have to hold on
to so that you don't slip and fall off and everything.
And we were like, what is this?
And then there's signs that are like, beware of snakes,
beware of wasps, beware of bears beware of monkeys and we
were like in a dress while hiking well I didn't know that
this was going to be a hike there was no I'm surprised there
was no sign that said beware of boars considering boars have
been attacking people but
yeah little did we know like the trail was like another hour
and it was getting dark and we're like how do we how do we
go home we had to there was like we were right next to the
Ryokan but we had like had to go down the street to start
the trail it was like craziness how it was like yeah it was
very long so no we did not get to go to the to the temple
and i guess our trip to osaka was a waste except the next
day when we decided to go to universal studios japan and
that was my first time at universal studios japan so yes
this is my third theme park in two weeks
This is my third day park in two weeks of a trip.
Something similar happened to be in Poland when my taxi
driver stopped.
He walked behind his car to the other driver and we heard a
very loud audible slap.
That's crazy.
Don't think he's over here with the five gifted.
Oh.
What was it the last?
Yes, it was the last one of this trip.
But, um...
It was extremely cold.
It was so...
So cold.
It was so cold.
And I...
We rode quite a good amount of stuff.
Um...
I rode the Jaws ride.
And some of the water got in my mouth.
And I think now I'm Spider-Man.
souvenir yeah yeah was it yummy water no I was just so
shocked so shocked month six of asking Vintam
people getting the fights in the middle of the street is so
fitting considering how many king of fighter stages are
located in Osaka it makes sense I once visited 10 theme
parks during a three-week vacation.
So many!
10?
Also, Teku, thank you so much for the gifted.
Yeah, I love theme parks so much, though.
Is that how you got sick?
No, I was sick before then.
I got sick like a couple days after getting to Japan, but
then I recovered a couple days.
That was pretty nice.
It wasn't so bad.
That was my birthday November.
16th.
Stella!
Happy belated birthday!
I'm sorry I missed it!
Unreal Citizen, welcome back!
Thank you!
What did Mario do?
I'm getting to it, I'm getting to it!
Oh my gosh.
Let's see, what else did I do?
I have to skip a whole day because I cannot talk about that.
It's redacted information.
But I did get to play the OG Idolmaster and I posted my P
cards on on on Twitter.
I'm Minto P and I am the producer of Yori, aka Minto Baby.
That's my baby.
Minto Baby.
But this is redacted.
That's redacted day.
Well, I want to talk about it so bad because it was an
absolutely horrifying experience.
It was of the scariest things I've ever done in my entire
afterlife so I will talk about it when I can talk about it.
Hey Mark welcome back thank you.
Huh yeah unfortunately I cannot say anything yet.
We won't tell anybody.
Your cover of Kanzi Gavite yesterday was my third most
played song.
Oh my gosh thank you.
Thank you thank you.
Good scary or bad scary?
Uh, no, it was, it was good, just very scary.
Oh, but, um, did Universal.
The rides were very fun.
Um, and then I was already feeling my tummy was feeling
pretty pretty sick uh uh the morning of and then we go to
nintendo nintendo world and i was i was feeling okay it was
very cold and i was like oh oh my gosh wait one thing that
we went on though was the spy family ride I forgot to talk
about CODEN!
Wait, okay, okay.
Before we talk about Mario and how much I hate this guy.
Oh my gosh!
Good job, Mickey.
Get through redacted.
Thank you!
I'm embarrassed.
Nancy Drew is in my top three most watched games.
Phoebe!
Thank you.
Woo!
Okay, before I get to Mario...
The Spy Family ride was so awesome.
I've never ridden a VR roller coaster before but it was
pretty fun I love you welcome home I almost said welcome
home I almost said welcome home I love you too
I did say welcome home no I didn't no Phoebe said that to me
and I almost said welcome home too
Enjoy your meal.
You too.
I get to thank you.
Glad you had a good time, man.
Yeah, I did.
Um.
But, uh...
Uh...
Yeah, and I've never done a VR roller coaster before.
It made me...
I'm very not good with VR stuff and headset stuff.
It makes me...
Extremely...
Extremely sick.
What are the microwavable KitKat flavors?
Microwavable?
Oh?
Even the newest stuff?
Yeah, I'm extremely bad with like any...
Like 3D rides?
I'm extremely bad with...
I'm very bad with VR stuff.
Like, I...
I can do any sort of roller coaster.
Easy peasy.
The second you put me in a movable machine with 3D...
With, like, those little 3D glasses.
I'm done for.
It's so bad.
Luckily, because the Spy Family ride was...
Also...
It was a roller coaster.
I was totally fine.
Spinning rides are the worst.
I'm totally fine with spinning rides.
I just like VR and 3D stuff makes me so sick.
It never works properly for me.
So like, it's like the one thing with the Spy Family ride
was like the...
Yeah, what's it called?
The frame rate was a little off, so it made me a little bit
sicky, but...
What about drop rides?
Well, I don't like drop rides too much, but they don't make
me sick at all.
Regular rides don't make me sick.
It's only stuff with 3D.
Or 4D or whatever.
So, yeah.
Ooh.
But the Spy Family ride, luckily, I was more okay with than
not okay.
And then, oh my gosh.
The first thing we did was there was a Detective Conan 4...
I don't want to call it a 4D ride.
It was a 4D experience.
sounds like car sickness yes i get really bad car sick i do
i do also oh phil thank you so much for the 50 kids and
thank you thank you otter watcher thank you so much for the
five kids and thank you thank you thank you guys thank you
so much for those that don't know i love detective conan i
love detective conan but this was this was also a first for
me I don't want to say it was a ride.
Your seats did lift up.
He said the line.
But half of it was also with live actors.
So they had, if you know the show, they had an actor for
Sonoko.
And they had an actor for Ron.
For Ronchan.
And it was so cool!
Like they were on the stage and they were interacting with
Kodin and...
Amuro-kun and he was so cool and Kaito Kid came and um he
was trying to steal the jewel and Conan's proportions are
absolutely fucked man that kid his head is ginormous and his
little tiny body and Amuro was so small and skinny I don't
understand the proportions at all but it was still so fun
and then Kaito Kid was like swinging around and then and
then Kaito Kid you hear him And there's a Kaito Kid actor,
and he comes from the ceiling!
And he's, like, walking around, and Ron is, like, doing
karate at him.
And they're, like, behind me!
And I'm like, whoa!
Whoa!
It was...
It was so awesome.
I was screaming, and I was...
I was freaking out!
It was so awesome!
So, yeah.
It was really, really cool.
I've never had, like, a show like that before.
It was so great.
I haven't watched Detective Conan in quite some time now.
I'm, like, a couple hundred episodes behind.
I stopped at, like, episode 900-something.
Right?
I don't remember.
But...
Maybe I did make... Actually, no, I did make it to
episode...
I did make it past a thousand.
I'm a pretty big Conan fan.
But I'm not...
Caught up.
I think they're...
Yeah.
I'm several hundred episodes behind myself.
Yeah?
I've watched...
Up until, like...
When I stopped, I had watched every single episode.
Yeah Yeah, yeah
So Are you caught up on Zets?
I'm I think I'm I guess two episodes behind though of Zets
because I was gone But yeah, went to went to
USJ so we had so much fun And then the night we went to
Nintendo World.
And I was like, hey guys.
Am I going to be okay on the Mario Kart ride?
And they were like, it's not VR.
It's AR.
And I was like, okay.
I was not okay on the Mario Kart ride.
No.
And the whole day too.
It's even worse.
What's even worse is the whole day I was like, Mario I hate
that guy I hate him I hate Mario and they were like why do
you hate Mario Minto and I was like because I played that
game for like 11 hours and you know what he says I'm a tire
and you know what I say I do all that work Mario not you and
so after Mario ride oh it was so bad on the ride itself I
was like okay so if you're not sure how the Mario cart ride
works you put on this big old helmet and then they attach a
visor like thing to you they look like like goggles almost
and those show so the ride moves and then also And then
also, there's like the characters in front of you on the
goggles.
It's very confusing.
And...
For me, some people can kind of like see the track and see
the characters at the same time.
For me, it was like focus on one or the other.
And the point of the game is you shoot the shell.
at like the other characters and you get coins and so like I
said I have big issues with VR I have big issues with like
3d and stuff my eyes are only focused on so that's why I
can't look at my phone when I'm in the car I can't read when
I'm like in the car things like that like if I'm in the
passenger seat I can't do anything like that so I have to be
fully focused on like the and like where we're driving,
things like that.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
So, um...
So I'm fully focused on the characters that I'm shooting
because my eyesight is focused on that.
I'm not seeing anything that's happening around me.
And so it's...
And I'm like half trying to see what's going on and half
trying to shoot these characters.
And I don't know if maybe...
it's meant to be like that it seems like you're supposed to
look at them at the same time but my eyes could not focus on
both at the same time you know so
I get to the end of the ride and it stops and I was like I
was like okay that was a ride and then I get off And I was
like, oh no, oh no, oh, oh, I'm not gonna make it.
And I go outside and I'm, it's, okay, if you've never been
to Nintendo World, it's the most overstimulating location
you'll ever be in your entire life or afterlife, depending
on if you're alive or not.
I'm sitting on a stinking toad stool thinking like, just try
not to, the children around me with with ectoplasm all over
the floor i'm all i see is like piranha plants being like in
my peripheral i see i see yoshis i see toads i see
everything moving all at once and i mean and that is the
worst feeling when you are sick when you are feeling so sick
the worst feeling is having literally everything in the
world around you being like the most insane everything I
ended up having to go to the toad cafe and I got like some
hot yuzu drink and um yeah bad idea because after that I was
like I'm not gonna make it and so I went to the party
and did what I needed to do.
I'm throwing up to the underwater music.
Yeah, I threw up because of Mario.
And I have, what's funny too is the cue for the Mario Kart
ride is amazing.
It's so awesome.
It's so much fun.
I have a million pictures from the cue.
And it literally, as I scroll through them, it feels like
moments before disaster.
This is like...
BM before Mario.
My pictures are that and PM post Mario.
He left out that Mario pretty much exclusively.
Only eats mushrooms whenever he can.
It's only natural you would eventually become enemies.
Yeah, it's so true.
But the queue for the ride is amazing.
I plan on visiting USJ next year.
And I was so sad too because I didn't feel well.
I missed out on Donkey Kong ride.
I was so sad.
So I just have to go back another time, I guess.
One day I'll go back.
I just wanted to ride DK.
Okay.
Astrobot would never do you like that.
Oh my gosh, imagine an Astrobot ride?
It would be the cutest thing ever.
It's gonna ask what happened at Nintendo World because you
said how you'll get back to Mario later after your spy filmy
ride experience.
Talk that Mario sounded so vicious now we know why.
Just got confirmation that I passed my paramedic course!
Wanted to spread the love.
Miguel!
Congratulations!
Congrats, congrats!
Sony will have to make their own theme park.
I wish that like IPs...
I wish...
I wish we could like...
I understand why it's important, but sometimes I wish we
could just throw IPs away.
Imagine the amazing theme parks we could get if we could
just have like...
Have a video game themed park, you know?
It would be so awesome.
If we could just have, like, you know, like a Resident Evil
area.
You know, or...
Just...
Super Smash World.
Yeah, exactly.
Like Fortnite.
Yeah, like Fortnite.
It would be so awesome.
It would be so cool.
Oh, yeah.
Metal Gear area.
Metal Gear.
escape room which did exist but yeah it would be so awesome
oh yeah USJ does have resident evil at times they have for
Halloween they have like Leon come out and stuff um uh they
had some monster hunter cafe while I was there I did not get
to go into it though um But like an actual theme park where
it's like, oh my gosh, like a...
Oh, it would be so cool!
A Resident Evil themed like laser tag.
Winter Cedar, happy birthday!
Happy, happy birthday!
But yeah, so USJ happened.
Then I went back to Tokyo for a couple days.
I went and saw Zootopia too!
Um...
Uh...
Uh, it was fine.
I watched it in Japanese.
Um...
So I kind of want to see some of the parts in English, what
they say.
Uh...
Did you enjoy the three Kojima lines?
Yeah, I did.
So, I didn't hate the movie at first.
I don't hate it now even.
I was just kind of like...
Hmm.
I was like enjoying it during the movie, you know?
I was like kind of brain off just having fun.
And then afterwards I was like...
I heard I made references to a certain comic.
I made references to the Shining.
I liked that part.
That was funny.
Apparently, there was supposed to be like a four-minute
scene that was replicating the speech, like the talk between
Clarice and Hannibal, but they took that out.
Did I have subtitles?
No.
I had no subtitles.
I had to just be...
I had to be kind of like brain-on the entire time because it
was in Japanese.
Um.
But, uh...
So that was kind of like a little draining because of it.
because I had to be so like Nihongo on Nihongo on uh um but
I thought that it would be okay because maybe um it's a
Disney movie hmm uh but okay the movie slight spoilers here
for anybody um here I'll I'll put up a thing just because
the movie is so...
Actually, wait, the movie's been out a couple weeks here,
no?
Wait, the movie's been out a couple weeks in America, no?
I think?
It's been out like a week.
Which movie?
Zootopia, too!
I don't think Western jokes translate well when dubbed to
Japanese.
Some were funny.
Hi, Oivo.
Some were, like, kind of...
Okay, hold on.
I'll just write Zootopia.
I'll just write spoilers.
Because it is a newer movie.
I don't want to be that person.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Here, let's do...
Zootopia 2 spoilers.
Okay, I'll turn it off.
I'll take it down once I'm done talking about it.
Okay, so the movie takes place one week.
after the first movie, which I'm kind of sick of them doing
this.
Please, if you're going to make a sequel, but the movie
takes five years to make, I am not still in the setting of
Zootopia 1 anymore.
Like, it is...
That's quick.
Yeah!
A week after the...
Yeah, Incredibles 2 moment.
The same thing, exactly, exactly.
Like, I'm just like, my brain is not...
in Zootopia 1 anymore.
Like, I am ready for the future.
So sad when I went to see FNAF 2, but my local theater
didn't have Toy Freddy Bucket.
No!
Guys, I have to pee.
Hold on.
Pea time.
I have to pee real quick.
Hold on.
I'll talk more in a second.
Sorry.
I also got some cereal.
Okay, back to Zootopia.
Back to Zootopia.
I'm two spoilers.
I was starting to get hungry.
With cereal?
My favorite honey bunches of words.
Okay.
Starts one week.
After.
After Zootopia 1.
They even do like a little recap.
Did you wash your hands?
Oh my god!
I...
Oh my god.
Because I was gone for two weeks, my soap dispenser kind of
like...
It has a very thin nozzle, the one that I use.
It's...
It's very thin.
And I went to wash my hands last night when I got home.
It spit to the right.
I was like, no!
It like exploded.
And then...
Exploded to the right.
And I was like, no!
This morning I like covered it.
I was like, okay, I'm gonna cover it.
And I've covered like the front and the right part.
I was like, okay, it's not gonna explode on me today.
It exploded to the left.
And so this time I like cupped it.
Like really, I was like, okay.
It can't go left or right now.
It went up.
Just
up.
Oh, man.
Okay, it takes place one week after Zootopia went.
There's like this book that explains
how Zootopia was formed.
It's like this Lynx cat that wrote it.
And he's like, I'm the creator of Zootopia.
it's not him it was really this snake this snake's mom is is
is the one that created it and they like that they there's
like this there's like this uh son of the links that that is
like I'm an outcast in my family and I want to be I want to
put a stop to my family because they're evil and but of
course he's the twist villain I called it from as soon as I
saw him I was like okay this guy's the twist villain sure
whatever and uh he was he was like I don't actually want to
stop my family I want to be accepted by my family and I'm
like you are so stupid you already were what it was so
obvious it was so obvious the snake that they advertise is
like the is like a villain.
So basically, I never realized.
But in Zootopia 1, did you guys notice that there were no
reptiles?
I guess I never thought about it.
But in Zootopia 2, the cat was just like, I don't want
reptiles in Zootopia.
And so that's why, like, I guess because of the snake or
whatever.
No birds either.
Well, at the end, after the credits, they hint at a bird
wait is that why at the end after the credits they show like
a little feather oh there's gonna be a third zootopia in 30
37 and it'll be it'll take place 30 seconds after the first
zootopia ended or the second one ended
I love going to Disney movies for the past decade asking
who's going to be the twist villain I know Disney movies
gosh but the thing is Nick in the first movie very
charismatic very cool this guy he he's a bad boy you know
he's a bit of a bad boy this movie he they turned him into
an absolute weenie the whole time he's like um judy you
shouldn't be doing that watch out for your safety judy um
judy uh excuse me judy and and judy was a every she's like
oh my gosh we are we are we're partners but she would
abandon him nick would be like judy i need help over here
never would help him would just go off and do her own thing
i was like what is what This is... It was so... It's such a
hard watch with both of them.
And... And then at the same time...
At the same time...
So, they... They...
If you are wondering if their relation... How their
relationship is.
Their relationship status.
This is what they would do.
This is the exact type of dialogue they would say.
They would be like...
You're the most important person in my life.
I never want a different partner.
A different work partner than you.
Oh, my life was so boring and terrible until I found you.
I never wanted to join the police academy to become a police
officer.
I wanted to do it only because I wanted friends.
And in Japanese, there's a line that Judy records with her
little like, carrot thing.
In Japanese, he says, what was it?
Was it like, I think it was, I think it was, I think it was,
but I need to know what he says.
Or was it, I don't know if he calls her, I don't even
remember.
I know he calls her ninjin, like carrots.
He calls her ninjin.
But, what does he say in English?
He says, I love you?
Does he actually?
But my God, the baiting, they, They debated them like crazy.
Like their relationship.
They would say they would do the most like...
Oh, I love you so much!
As my partner.
I...
I never want to be with anyone else.
As a police officer.
It was like the worst!
He says I love you.
No way.
Wow.
Still spoiling?
All done now.
I'm fine.
I'm done.
now I
love my officer partner yeah it was very much the hug
the post credit Judy kept replaying it I know I know let
them kiss let them kiss what
about gojumbo's part he was like this little mole guy they
bust down his wall and he goes yeah And then there's another
part where he goes, he says, he says something, I don't
remember.
But he says like, just like that.
At the beginning, there's a, there's like a little, oh my
gosh, I can't remember what the animal is called.
She's the counselor lady for the partners.
At the beginning of the film, that's voiced by Nana Mizuki.
I was like, whoa!
Yeah, he's done it again!
He's done it again!
He says Kojima Kami Nandes.
Oh, the last part of my trip.
Day before I left.
I went to a concert!
Guys, I only got to go to one concert.
I didn't do anything idols this time besides meeting
Nemo-chan.
But...
I went to a concert for Asaka!
My favorite Ani song singer, she's so sweet!
She's so, so nice!
Minto Judy fanfic.
Imagine?
Wait, why?
I don't want to be paired with Judy, though.
She was so not nice in this movie.
Yeah, I went to Asaka concert and it was so nice.
And I got to talk to her actually a little bit after the
show.
And she sang, she sang Waya Waya Waya, which is a song that
I did at Fantastic Reality.
And so we were like, Waya Waya Waya together.
And I was like, I was so happy.
She's so sweet.
She's so, so nice.
Yeah.
Love her.
Love Isoca.
And she was like, can we take a selfie?
And I'm like, so I'm on her phone now.
It's really crazy how becoming a YouTuber has had me like
meet so many of these people that I've like loved for so
long.
I don't know.
Yeah, I was the spirit photography for real.
And then when I also did...
Yeah!
That was fun and scary.
Stop doing that YouTube emote.
The angry one?
That one?
Stab it.
Lip readers, did you catch that?
Face red droopy eyes, face red droopy eyes, face red droopy
eyes.
I haven't seen a FNAF movie yet.
I heard it's great FNAF movie.
I heard it's bad movie.
I can't believe that.
That's crazy.
I know.
That's the perfect description.
Really?
Okay.
Can I hear the FNAF TikTok trend?
No?
I still do eyes glowing red.
Why?
So I can do the YouTube emote.
FNAF spoilers?
I had such a fun time in Japan and a lot of that was thanks
to your recommendations and love of Japanese culture that
you've given me.
Whoa, Nexi!
Amazing idols who asked me why I was there were excited to
hear about- No, that's so embarrassing!
Sorry, I'm eating my food.
Oh wait, can I go get some more tea?
I'm Dorsi.
Was that announced?
Wait!
Hold on?
Hold?
So I don't quite have my own PC case I do, but I don't
Let me see Look at this, guys You guys, look
Look If you're going to the Asa Yoru Made event This week,
you have a chance to win one And then also There will be an
online giveaway for one as well so you could win one as well
but they won't be sold they will not be sold but you could
win your own with photo case yeah yeah so it's so pretty oh
my gosh oh my gosh wait this is my first time seeing like
this picture as well so it's so cute and Chocolat did the
art and it's It's so...
Stinking pretty.
Yeah.
So...
If you would like to win!
A PC, a Minto PC case.
You should enter!
How do we enter online?
I don't think the details are up yet.
Let me see.
Plan...
We're hosting an online giveaway.
Oh wait, height.com...
Wait.
Ah!
Oh!
Oh, there is a link!
Just kidding.
Copy link.
Enter to win the height Minto PC case.
Wait.
Ugh.
Let me just copy the thing.
Uh, let me just copy their link.
That.
There you go.
Pian message.
Welcome back, Minto.
Not like I missed you or anything.
Deku!
I guess I have to make a new PC.
It's so pretty.
It's so clean.
It's so clean looking.
It's like exactly the kind of PC that I would want.
Ram is so expensive now.
I heard about that, right?
I would just transfer everything.
everything from my current setup into into this into this
case yeah I wouldn't I wouldn't buy all new parts I think
everything that I have would fit in here probably I don't
even know what are the prices now for RAM trip
$1,000 five four five times the price?
No way.
Damn,
that was $50 per stick when I bought it in 2023 is like $400
now.
You know, guys, that really sucks.
Hopefully everybody has PCs good enough right now that you
don't have to upgrade and uh that yeah that's just all yeah
hope that it goes down event back down eventually
pray for the bubble crash yeah yeah yeah
stinking ai
We can download more RAM Once there were beanie babies Then
the boo-boo is now the latest collector found RAM
We must have hope That's all we can have honestly That's all
we got
Download more Download more
I'm looking at my sticks right now being like Don't die on
me you do.
Don't you die on me.
How jet-lagged are you?
I'm pretty jet-lagged.
I took a nap earlier and now I'm like, am I going to be able
to sleep tonight?
Hmm.
You wouldn't download a car.
My car is full of RAM.
I could not have picked the worst time to upgrade.
No!
There's slim chance it'll be in the mint okay I hope so yeah
I'm sorry that I can't like sell them sell them which uh you
know that's okay honestly I feel that there have been so
many vtuber cases being created lately that I'm like I I
there's such also an expensive product that I felt that it
would be tough for for people so maybe in the future though
if you have maybe I could do like PC stickers or something
stickers meant that you meant for your for your PC case if
you are so keen on you know getting something mmm I'm Minto
phone case.
Phone cases are even more difficult, though, I feel.
Because there's so many different types of phones.
Hmm.
Mint Phantom Brand Ram.
I'm, okay, I'm, I'm creating my own RAM company right now.
Yeah, so many models.
Yeah, yeah.
My 11-month-year-old PC.
Wait, 11-month-old PC.
month year old PC dot wait it was 3k to 4k to bill but I'm
having someone look at it did he pray for it to work no
wireson I hope it works come back come back come back come
back one thing about Universal Japan but that I did not
expect is the staff there are so so kind they're so nice
there like even nicer than any of the staff that I'm would
run into at Disney like Like, which...
I thought Disney had amazing service, like Tokyo Disney.
But USJ stuff are crazy.
There was, after the Conan ride, I went to go buy some Conan
merch.
And I had, like, a Toru Amuro hair tie.
And I was getting...
Oh, here's where my gotcha luck went crazy.
I was getting two things that were, like, little keychains.
one keychain I really wanted because it's the same keychain
as uh um as Ron from detective Conan I wanted her same
keychain and then another one was a gotcha box for uh some
of the characters but they were like usj themed like they
were wearing different merch or like themed to the different
rides it was really cute and um and so I she sees the lady
checking me out she sees that I have the Amuro hair tie and
she's like and she looks at the box that I'm getting and
she's like she's like do you like Amuro kun and I was like
yeah I love Amuro kun and so she looks at my box and she
like puts her hands together like she's praying and she says
please I hope this box has Amuro kun please I hope this box
has Amuro kun she blessed my poles she literally poles in
real time it was so cute and then it was like no one has
ever done that for me before like at a store it was so so
cute and so i opened all my stuff outside the store my box
amaro-kun so i went inside and i showed her and i was like i
got amaro and she was so happy for me It was so cute!
And then, the keychain that I wanted, I got two packs.
Both of them were the same keychain.
Crazy!
Yeah.
So, I got that.
And then, um...
There was one other thing that I had done a gotcha pull for,
and I got it first try.
I don't remember what it was.
Right up is real I know I was like whoa My polls And
everybody All my friends kept commenting on it They were
like They were like You'll Your polls are Are so lucky Like
what is your luck this trip?
Never punished I guess You should give her a PC case I don't
know She'll need it
I'm almost done with my share oil.
It's like oatmeal at this point.
Mario throw up.
Oh, this was before Mario, though.
I guess that did balance out my day throwing up after Mario.
Hmm.
Yeah.
Can you eat with my mouth open?
No!
Weren't you gonna get tea?
Oh!
I was gonna get tea.
Thank you.
I'll be right back.
Two seconds.
Let me put a thing.
Tea.
Hi!
Oh, I was like, where did my music go?
I was like, huh?
I I put on my headphones and it was silence.
What kind of tea?
Just I'm getting my cha.
Yawn.
Don't tell us.
Don't say yawn.
Glad the trip felt like an actual vacation.
There were some things, like, uh...
I think with, uh...
Leah's thing did not feel like a vacation, obviously.
And leading up to it, I was still, like, having to practice
the dance every night.
I learned the dance that week.
I don't know if I told her that.
Don't tell her that.
Don't tell her I said that.
But, uh...
I learned it that week.
Because I was so...
I was way too busy to learn it before then.
So...
Oopsie.
Actually, I might have told her that.
I might have been like, well, yeah.
I barely practiced.
No, I did practice.
But, yeah.
But now I'm back!
And, uh, it was...
It was fun!
I'm so sorry.
I said I would stream.
And I did a Twitter space.
And I'm so sorry.
I've learned...
my lesson though.
From now on, if I know that I'm going to be hanging out with
people most of the time.
And I knew how packed my trip was.
And still, I was like, I was like hopeful.
You know, I always, I always try to, I always, I always,
what's the word?
I am ambitious.
I'm ambitious about wanting to stream.
I love streaming.
I always want to hang out with you guys.
So, but now that I know if I'm going to be with people, It's
gonna be a vacation.
It's gonna be...
No streaming, most likely.
Tudor space is better than nothing.
Thank you.
I'm so sorry.
Don't bite off more than you can chew.
I really...
I guess because, like, you know, also...
Oh my gosh, I...
When I...
What was I gonna say?
When I went to go hang out with Nimmy and Phoebe.
too like I I also was just like I did try I did stream that
part I did stream then oh the tag fell into my tea but yeah
live your afterlife thank you I
sipped it and then the string got in my mouth so my first
live stream of you welcome thanks Wait, you even join
membership!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you.
Love hearing from you at all.
Even the Twitter space.
I feel like I'm pretty bad in general about tweeting.
So...
Yeah, I do my best.
You peak tweet.
I do?
Oh my gosh, I've been seeing pictures from the The Asa Yoru.
The Asa Yoru event.
And I'm seeing so many faces I recognize.
And look at, wait, can I post these?
Let me ask.
Wait.
Can I, um, show these on stream?
Um, Mane-san.
Are you awake?
Mane-san.
I don't think so.
The last work stream on the other trips, you said you wanted
to show us a picture from your hotel when you got back.
Did you still want to show it?
Big Binto love love.
Oh!
I know!
I know what I was gonna say.
Mani-san, Okite-nai!
Okite-nai!
Mani-san, Okite-o-o-o-o-o-o-o-o-o-o-o-o-o-o-o-o!
Okite-o-o-o-o-oite-o-o-oite-o-oite!
Let's see.
I did have a picture.
From my hotel.
I think I talked about...
Wait, where is it?
Oh, I think I took it with a different camera.
Okay, hold on.
Let me triple check these photos.
I think I talked about how...
The haunted hotel?
Okay.
No, if this is...
During the work stream...
Which... Oh my gosh, the work stream was supposed to be me
learning the dance.
For it was supposed to be me!
Me learning the dance!
That was supposed to be it!
Okay, hold on.
Let me pose... Let me... Okay.
But no, this was going to be the hotel that I stayed at when
I was hanging out with Nimmy and Phoebe.
so i talked about it i think i don't actually know if i
mentioned it maybe i didn't because of i didn't want to give
the hotel away or anything um but basically the hotel i
stayed at was very oh my gosh the bathroom was so bizarre
because uh because i had a stinking rubik's cube as like the
handles for the shower and stuff so give me a second okay
this one is okay I know I sent this to people
let me crop this one a little bit because yeah it was like a
puzzle cube I was like what is this what the heck is this
okay so this the the um what's the word sorry i'm so jet
lagged so i can't think of any words or phrases today
the the sink and i'm still i'm multitasking so i'm trying to
the sink was not so bad but let me just show you the sink
real quick oh whoa zoomed in the sink was like this and it
like you see the handles the thing about them is they were
so hard to grip they were extremely hard to grip and they
like would not move yeah they were square they would hurt my
hand every time i tried to i tried to use it
those are for charms oh like a like a keychain oh but this
is not the problem This is not the problem.
The sink.
The sink was just a little annoying.
Hold on.
Let me do this.
I will show you.
Da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da.
This is the shower.
What is this?
And there's no indication of which way is hot and which way
is cold.
There was no, like, little blue dot or little red dot.
And it was also extremely difficult to push.
I think I took a video.
I'm not going to play it, though.
I took a video of me, like, because I was showing people.
I was like trying to push it.
Minecraft Hotel.
I know.
It's so weird.
It's extremely...
I had a puzzle cube as my shower handle.
What even is that?
You can see, it's funny too.
You can see it's like a little fogged up.
I was like about to get in the shower.
Then I was like, I need to take a picture of the stinking
thing.
The Minecraft shower.
To unlock hot water, you must complete the Millennium
puzzle.
Or bathe in the shadow realm.
Last time I was house hunting, I had a saying when I came
across weird designs.
Things people would do.
Decisions were made.
Definitely applies here.
Yeah, I just don't understand.
like minimalism has gone too far it has gone way too far
when your shower handle is a 4D cube Levent configuration
has shower handle it's so weird resident evil room design oh
man but yeah I think that's the Pretty sure that was what I
was wanting to show a picture of.
Anything else that I want to show from my Japan trip, I'll
post on Twitter.
Because I do have a handful of, like, photos from Fujisan
and Tee.
I can post stuff from the theme parks.
So, I will post those on Twitter.
I just don't feel like going through them right now.
I don't feel like going through it and making sure
everything's good.
You know.
Fuji-san!
But yeah!
I'm happy to be back, though.
I can't wait to play games tomorrow.
I just want to stream so much now.
I think, honestly, like I did have so much fun.
But I hit my limit where...
Of how long I...
Like, would go without streaming.
You know what I mean?
Like, how long I would want to go or anything.
What are we playing tomorrow?
I have no idea.
um honestly i haven't made my schedule yet i do have a
collab this week me um me and the dented the girlies no
there will be a schedule just tomorrow just tomorrow two
week vacation feels about right i think i feel like two
weeks is too long no i'm okay with like a one i think from
now on
than two weeks, I'm gonna try, or two weeks and longer, I'm
gonna try and stream.
If it's like a one week, I'm gonna take it as a vacation,
you know?
Yeah.
I passed my final!
Your boss helped me through it!
Shiyaku Sakakura!
Congratulations!
Mostly in internet time as long.
Yeah.
Now that I'm home, like, it feels very, like, the maid cafe,
I don't even remember.
recognize it a little bit.
Any plans to try out the Yakuza series?
Eventually, I'd like to.
Yakuza is just extremely long.
So...
Hmm.
Or...
At least have like a...
If I had known that I wouldn't have been able to stream, I
would have had like a 24-hour thing up, you know?
I even...
had like in my calendar I don't like I don't what's the word
like set stream times for while I'm gone but I like made
even like a whole list of games that I could do I wanted to
stream like one I wanted to stream at least four or five
times while I was gone but we'll just do that we'll just do
that no we'll just do all the stuff game you plan on
finishing it yeah limbo i didn't even i thought i would be
able to do it i really thought i would have time and in the
end no we're so so insanity such insanity did you reach 50
games yet no we're at thank you welcome back here thank you
thank you we are at how many games do I need left ten more I
need ten wait 11 more 11 more games by December 31st oh wait
that's a lot of games wait that's a lot of games okay well
we'll finish limbo I'll finish that this week two games a
stream yeah I think almost maybe until like the end of the
year it's gotta be oh I wanted to start uncharted and I
wanted to start Alan Wake okay hmm
Game Awards this Thursday.
Oh my gosh, wait, we gotta know what Jeff Keeley has in the
desert.
Half-Life 3!
Alan Wake would be fun to watch.
I don't want to play it.
I want to play it.
Uncharted and Alan Wake are both 10-ish hours.
It's doable.
Yeah, I think I'll play those as, like, some longer,
quote-unquote, longer games.
Uh, this, this month, and then, um, do a bunch of one-shots
for everything else.
Yeah, yeah.
Arc is evil.
Welcome back.
Thank you.
Alan Wake Peak is absolutely peak if you get to it.
That's why I want to actually that's why I want to start
Alan Wake because I've heard such good things about two that
I really want.
want to I want to play it but I have to play one oh okay all
right I'll come up with a bunch of games I've everybody I
already asked people for games so so I have a bunch of one
shots that I can do we got this we got this 11 games in and
And I'll be taking off a couple days because of Hallmat.
But I actually will be bringing my setup for Hallmat and I
do want to stream.
But playing games there might be a little difficult.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
They'll figure it out.
System Shock 2 just got a remaster with four-person
multiplayer.
The single-player campaign is a nail-biter.
System Shock 2.
I don't even know that game.
Oh, I do know the skin.
I recognize the cover.
Electric boogal.
Well, guys, thank you for the very warm welcome back.
Thank you!
I don't feel so jet lagged, but I do worry that I won't be
able to sleep tonight, maybe.
Um, but uh, Yeah!
Excited!
Um...
I'm happy to be back streaming!
Oh, two weeks was way too long.
Way too long.
Even though I had so much fun.
Tuarko!
Thank you so much!
My dog goes over, thank you!
Glad you had so much fun.
Maybe...
We maybe missed you a tiny bit.
Just maybe.
Possibly.
I hope you had some really good rest tonight.
Thank you!
I slept for like 10 hours last night, you guys.
I went to sleep at...
Midnight in Wugabaten.
And then...
Which is surprising, I felt.
I stayed up as long as I could until midnight.
Was it midnight?
Maybe 11.
I don't know.
And then I took a nap, even in the day.
I slept, baby.
There's this girl in Japan.
She's quite popular right now.
I'm named Shinako.
Hold on.
Yes.
Nako ASMR is her YouTube channel.
She's a very popular YouTube channel where she does like the
crunchy like food ASMR.
Where she'll like take a bite and it's like...
Like that.
It's not my kind of thing.
But you see her all over the place.
And one really cool thing about her is that she's like kind
of bringing like that like Haru Juku...
Like the old school style Harajuku-K back, you know?
So, um...
Glad to hear you had a fun trip with Time to Yourself.
Glad to have you back.
Thank you!
Thank you so much, Nami!
Um...
ASMR mukbang?
I think it's less mukbang, and it's more like...
She's eating...
Like, uh...
Aesthetic candies and things.
And they make a nice crunch.
And so some people like the crunching.
Thought you hated mouth crunching.
I literally just said it's not my thing.
Get the earwax out of your ears, Jeff.
But you see her all over Japan and you can tell it's her
because she
has like all the decor and like all the makeup and
everything.
So you're just like, oh, it's Shinako.
But one thing that's really funny about her is she's
extremely popular with children.
And I'm like, you know what?
If the children are listening and watching her, that's so
much better than like other things that they could be
listening or watching to.
So you know what?
Let her do her thing, you know?
And she has this one song called Hara Hara, and it's like
Parapara.
It's like Eurobeat, and she does Parapara.
And it's all about brushing your teeth.
Things like that.
Like she's really cute.
popular but i bring her up because um i had a dream that i
was at her concert yesterday but if you ever look up like
concerts of shinako it's so funny because it's like a bunch
of babies in the audience of all of them trying to do like
the para para routine which is very fast
they're just little babies flailing their arms around
It's so funny!
It's fun.
She's cute.
I like her.
I don't watch her ASMR though.
I wish I could show a video.
It's so funny.
It's so funny watching the babies.
Watching the babies flail.
I literally saw a video like that yesterday.
It might have been her.
I don't know why I was going to bring up my dream.
Oh, it's because I slept so much.
I was just talking about how I slept and then I was talking
about how I slept a lot and I had a dream.
That's it.
They're struggling and you're laughing.
What was the dream?
said it that I was at her concert the Shinako concert except
she was performing at a pool and so I was like swimming
around her while she was like performing and like all the
little children were on the side but Minto that really
happened Am I the baby?
I'm the baby, I'm the baby.
Well, anyways, thank you guys.
So, so much for the really warm welcome back.
I really warm welcome back.
Wait, really warm.
I appreciate it.
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you.
Thank you!
Not the mama.
The mama.
Welcome back and thanks for the stream.
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you.
Oh gosh.
Right at the very end of my trip.
I did get sick and then right at the very end of my trip my
throat started hurting.
So I hopefully am not...
Hopefully I can sleep away whatever I'm...
If I'm getting something again.
Hopefully not.
I just keep trying to drink lots of lots of tea Lots of warm
tea Thanks for not forgetting about us Of course I would
never I could never Unless I got amnesia Of the 5th degree
Minto's baby A baby confirmed Minto peas got her work over
Or is Minto pea the baby Miss you Minto Thank you Miss you
guys I didn't realize how much I missed your voice.
Yeah, the influenza was going around really bad.
Everybody, take your vitamins.
Lots of vitamin C, zinc, whatever else humans need.
Don't get sick.
Stay warm.
Stay safe.
Okay.
Don't sick.
No sick.
I was dang, influencers spread an influenza.
I'm an influence.
Oh my gosh, that reminds me of a story of once.
I think it was Keiaki Zaka had a song called Influenza.
Like, Influencer.
But when I first heard it, I was like...
No, I didn't say that.
Thank you, Tri-Frincess.
Thank you.
I said...
I was like, Influenza.
Like, why do they have a whole song about the flu and my mom
looked at me and she was like minto influencer i was like
influenza why does it keiakizaka have a song about
about in sickness
influenza to influenza Oh, so, so, so, so...
...muchigarachata!
My bad.
Okay, now I'm going for real.
Ah, Tsumito!
Thank you, everybody!
I miss you guys so much!
By subreddit.
Wait, I have a subreddit?
Huh?
Eatarashai!
Thank you for talking with me.
I had so much fun.
Bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye
bye bye bye bye See you tomorrow or see you when I see you
next Oh wait instead of moi moi boo what if I said moi moi
bye bye